Hello, Nashville.
I'm your local weatherman, Carden Corts.
I'm not an actual meteorologist, but I do know my sight words.
Today's weather report is brought to you by the letter C.
And also Pokemon cards!
Pokemon!
Gotta catch 'em all!
Let's take a look at today's weather in Nashville using our new weather simulator.
All I have to do is click this button.
I'm in a hurricane!
So cold.
Is there something behind me?
Ahh, this is more like it.
It's cloudy today in Nashville with a slight chance of rain.
The high today will be 51 degrees with a low of 33 degrees this evening.
But warmer weather is on the way.
Yesterday was the first day of spring and you know what that means...
Spring break!